[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is our daily live show that keeps
you updated on all the nerdy news you
need to know right here live from our
very own break room a nerd rock star a
new rock stars
today not about Starbucks though not
enough Starbucks guys what did we say
coming up on the show today we're
talking our new Transformers movie
Autobots roll out uh June 2 will be
happening sooner than you think uh
Riddler unconfirmed question mark
exclamation point
what a riddle is that a riddle an enigma
uh the only redo I care about is Matt
riddle you know what I'm talking about
okay bro
see what you did there I see what you do
we've got our She-Hulk predictions uh
and we're taking you to court actually
we're not gonna do it no we're not gonna
do that yeah
you're safe
this was a survey and a subpoenaed yet
I still have my court date set I do I
will still be appearing in court The
People's Court oh that's right uh I'm
Brandon Barrack who cares on the show
today we got Jay Washington they brought
me back yay Tommy
oh they can't oh Hands Across America oh
this is the most sexy mixed up Oreo ever
I can't believe we gave that away there
we go
the second hand is horrible wait hold
the whole time second hand
I want to say the
beginning was because I didn't give
Brandon coffee this morning and I didn't
know because he always says no every
time I offer him coffee for free
he thinks it's a euphemism
I would take that coffee any day of the
week uh speaking of a fellow coffee
lover we got Tommy bech told hi everyone
I don't do jokes anymore I'm all
business oh all about news so if you're
looking for jokes for me that was a
thing of the past well I retired from
Comedy and now I'm just a newsman wow
wow well you got a feeling for timing
tell me didn't bring any jokes today
he's all serious all the time we are
taking your super chat today and we
appreciate what you're sending them
sending them in the MJ 2997 already
sending in a Super Chat nerd rock stars
question mark love it well unfortunately
we're still just new rock stars
joke
um but for every 250 in super chats that
you send in today uh we're gonna give
Tommy what he's been begging for a
little extra time to talk about Andorra
okay I thought you were gonna give me
the other thing no we refused to give
you that oh okay uh uh if if we make 250
000 super chats We'll add a little
stoppage time to this uh football game
and we'll do some Andor now Jay we just
found out has not watched any Andor no
give him give him the camera of Shame
give them to him
we have the cancel sticker but we'll use
that stoppage time if we make it at 250
convince me we'll convince him
we'll get them there we'll get them
there we'll get him on Android I don't
know if you watched her last night folks
oh it was hot it was a great episode
there was lots of action lots of
intrigue and I think it's set up for a
pretty exciting back half most of my
contacts in the Star Wars Universe are
calling this one of the greatest
scripted shows lucasfilms has put out
yet and I think there's a lot to be
excited for in the future what about you
Brandon what has Wired Magazine said
about it Wired Magazine said pretty good
piece of something oh no
he's broken he's serious he's serious
Tommy no I'm just kidding where's
cinnamon said
wait
Jay's scared and onto our headline okay
let's do it fine do it yeah
it won't be the first time he does it
you guys Michelle yo and P Davidson
cassid and Transformers rise of the
Beast yo will be playing Mirage which is
like a bird-like character they're weak
it's like a reddish bird-kai character
British bird
we've saw eraser before but I don't
think
I don't know yeah right we've seen well
here's the thing Beast Wars has had most
of these characters so you've seen them
throughout that I'm gonna just hold this
like this uh so you said it's so close
it's just gonna be just like this on the
mouth
um sounds really weird like I'm holding
their tiny kid
um but it was in beast wars and whatnot
and so they brought him back and then
also the different G1 characters the
animals one was named air razor right so
they did that sometimes you get a name
from a predecessor because I I watched
the cartoon the animated cartoon I mean
I was born in 2002 so this is wrong for
my time but I've gone back to the uh the
resources the archives and I've seen the
Beast Wars show
animated and it was great it was how to
be right now and I do not have it yes
you do you just got it yeah that's where
you can find every terrible black movie
ever created that never got to Netflix
or Amazon or Hulu oh that's perfect
there's a QB
or not to be oh get out of here
either way the Transformer I like Siri
stop brick series taught me back
Transformers rise of the Beast will
partially be set in Brooklyn and Peru
it'll take place in the 90s this is your
cities
and Paddington comes a walking out uh
with his marmalade Prince King Charles
confirmed to voice Paddington oh
possibly oh I hope not he's the king now
we can do whatever he wants oh and his
side chick is about to be Queen she has
the greatest come up since Amber Rose I
mean not bad not bad for a while you
have to hang in there for a long time
but I don't think it's worth it what is
it maybe your fiber skin what is this
movie taking place in the 90s
sorry Tommy in the 1990s oh my God it's
really interesting so it's going to be
pre yeah this is yeah this is this is so
it introduces the maximals and the
terracons uh to the battle on Earth that
happened like before right between the
Autobots I mean the maximums are going
to be B boys
get epic like rap battles on cardboard
streets West Coast kind of stuff really
West Coast with Peru I guess yeah
wait a second
you're telling me the first Transformers
movie with Stan Witwicky uh-huh that
took place before that 20 years before
that there were there was a Transformers
war in Brooklyn that we all between
beast wars and Peru yeah
they'll answer these questions they're
going to answer this and Transformers
rise of the Beast I don't know guys
let's just watch National Geographic and
stick to reality stop stop absolutely
not absolutely we don't need to do this
channel anymore famously a National
Geographic can fake stuff
um
uh the famous clip of lemons going off a
cliff that's not a natural thing that
happens they were scared off that I do
have one question though I don't like
about this it's called the terracons and
not the Predacons yeah even though the
protocol so the Predacon started out as
a group in G1 Transformers G1 which made
the baddest combiner ever in Predaking
who was just a beast but the Predacons
were in Beach yeah it's called Predaking
which sounds like something crystal is
but
um then I will never be a certain Club
that's fine I don't think you want to be
at this club
um yes I do I really do but then you
know you go terracons that's another
group from G one the terracons were
their own small sect of Decepticons so
it's kind of like Maximus okay we all
accept that one right we all we all
include the maximals but I don't accept
any of this I don't like any effect I I
don't want to do around our whole show
today but do you think they dropped the
Predacons because of the Predator term
nature probably Sorry probably so the
the way that word has been charged with
so much yeah they were just like yeah
we'll just come terracons people say
terrorists right
that explains why the groom box
clearly we learned today that the
Transformer should have been our
discussion I guess I mean I could go
deeper Transformers all daylight which
we I didn't know but let's let's go to
our next headline Roblox in the chat if
you think any of this is exciting yeah
get some robots tomatoes in the chat if
you agree with Mr B this needs to go
away oh my God okay so Dune part two
releases two weeks earlier than
originally planned it's in November 2023
uh hours do you think that's because
it's coming out
hours after Disney pushback blades
release uh Warner Brothers revealed
they'll be releasing tune to part two on
Blade's old release date
honestly honestly you were planning you
were planning anyways now you can still
keep going get your make sure you get
your IMAX and your Dolby ticket there's
a lot of robots in the chat like one
tomato from my girl Tasha Tasha there
goes another tomato Maya
y'all focusing on tomatoes but not all
the it's a lot of ghosts the basement
was like Hey the black people gonna be
late so let's go over here
oh you guys I think they should have
called it Dune Park Dune oh oh that's a
good that's a good one that was a good
one I like that more than I'm joking I
like you anymore are they should call it
coming Dune like coming soon oh yeah
dude I do not have any Doom puns guys
I'm glad to hear that oh I I'm not going
to serve any but anyways third headline
Patty Jenkins has finished writing the
like the final scene in the final script
of Wonder Woman three
um this is the final script you guys so
I mean I mean they could alter it I
guess right it's like she's done it's
ready she's like it's done she says in
an interview in Italy that there is a
story that goes through these three
different movies as a whole but even now
I just wrote last week the final scene
of Wonder Woman three and I thought I
might be interested to see what happens
next so you'll never know indicating we
could possibly see a fourth Wonder Woman
movie
um which
it's hard I'll be honest I'm a threat
yeah okay okay uh yeah because after
Wonder Woman 84 we all have like really
hesitant about Wonder Woman threes the
thing is it's one person now or not one
person but they had too many hands in
the pot for one minute before yeah what
do you think Zazzle is going to do with
this now don't even talk because we
don't say he already canceled a whole
Batgirl movie was like yes I don't know
I hope Patty's pretty straightforward
with like there's way too many hands too
many hands in my second movie y'all back
up and let me do some work so I I have
faith in this I think without like you
know with no justice league no grand
plan for the DCU it's kind of like well
yeah let's focus on what this story for
Wonder Woman could be I would love to
see more Wonder Woman across time I
think that's like a fun element it's
great they can play with yeah
um I think also one it's like who a
bigger scope of thing who do they have
right now right it's like Shazam was
good uh Wonder Woman's the first movie
was really good they were writing on
those two
that's it
Aquaman was decent Aquaman just suffered
Aquaman suffered zombie stop it please
stop me stop you can't he can't he can't
he can't he won't Tommy Tom oh the man
like a pint of wine
a man suffer from being compared to
Black Panther in the trail of receipt
was seen so it was literally the same
movie so you know everybody got to see
Jason Momoa wet and with his hair and
just was like oh this is what Lisa Bonet
get the hit every night and it was like
we need to keep seeing it it was
distracting it was very distracting and
then you got to see him underwater with
his hair floating which by the way
looked really weird underwater it was
just dry how do you have dry hair
underwater is that the magic little
bubbles they could go in where they were
well remember they didn't they stopped
it James Watt said that after Justice
League he was like we're not doing
little air bubbles but so you had all
that but then
and we have the movie everybody was like
what happens yeah and again you thought
Wonder Woman 84 was going to be
something
and you just got Kristen wig turned into
a cheetah for no damn reason stop it it
was it was her fault it wasn't her fault
all I know is Optimus if you're a major
villain in the DC and you you want to at
least take out one member of the Justice
League have your fight in like Kansas or
something like that get away from the
ocean don't let Aquaman get anywhere
near you okay so when it comes to Wonder
Woman three you may say I'm a dreamer
but I'm not the owner stop
um
Barrel on to the fourth headline Colin
Farrell reveals you guys that where the
pair the penguin spin-off series is
going to begin which is really a big
deal and I don't know if he was supposed
to say this in the interview so he says
Colin Farrell it starts about a week
after the Batman ends so Gotham is still
somewhat underwater I read the script
first uh I read the first script of the
first episode and it opens up with the
feet splashing through the water in
Falcone's office which even just that
alone when I read it was like ah geez
how do you say that in his like uh his
uh oh when he was like oh
I think
I think that's really cool to be like
the the series because they're already
working aren't they already like green
lit to do another the Batman well they
were it's been very confusing about what
it is but it sounds like there's a
Penguin series and there's a Gotham I
heard that's been pool doesn't now well
yeah or they were gonna maybe right the
Gotham PD one was pulled because it was
supposed to be Abrams and all lemon
Reeves doing all this and they was just
like just do Colin Farrell because we
got him on the contract we got to do
something with them I'm I'm relieved
that he read the first script first I
think
I always said that's the way you start
at the beginning yeah I think that's a
very good place to start I think it's
it's pretty telling and I like the idea
of literally starting right where the
movie uh ended I like the idea of that
and I'm excited for the penguin uh fifth
headline fifth headline I think I'm not
keeping track really oh yeah no it
doesn't know when or if he'll play The
Riddler ever again you guys he had an
interview with comicbook.com and I don't
know if you guys know this but uh uh
Paul Daniel created his own origin comic
for the Riddler based off his character
he played in the Batman and I'm very
excited uh I love him to death also
really it's not out yet right no I don't
think so I know what the origin is he's
broke in Gotham right and he's trying to
swipe on the Wayne's dating app and it
won't work he can never get anybody and
so he's just like I'll kill everybody
start with Bruce Wayne and I'm like I'm
like dang flipping through those pages
uh he mentions in that set interview
though about the comic book origin he
says I have no clue if I will play The
Riddler in the live action again or not
but like I said I love making the Batman
so I think I certainly would which I
mean hopefully we see a little Cameo of
him in prison why specify live action
are we getting a new animated series or
anything I don't know are we getting a
new one I think it's just Paul Daniel
was just video games I think Paul Daniel
was just new to this universe I don't
think he means anything about it like
the blood's action originally I must
play a thespian you know Jay the whole
point of this channel is digging where
nothing needs to be dug out of uh sir
you start digging while I'm in here I'm
walking out sister I'll be breaking
ground here soon enough
do you think he's being a thirsty
thespian is he asking me no because he
said he's like I know but he's kind of
playing quite like oh I don't know they
even told me the thing is
the thing is in
in the interview when I'm joking in the
interview it was more about his comic
book or his comic book they just asked
that underneath so it was It was kind of
impressing him for even he didn't want
to really talk about it he wants to talk
about his comic book I don't want to
talk about it uh remember folks throw in
those super chats if you want a little
stoppage time for Andor Robin out there
is saying give me that sweet and or time
I love it yeah I love it too Rob we're
gonna get Jay to watch that show uh we
got more headlights to go through but
real quick I want to talk to you guys
about magic the Gathering Arena that's
right you know Magic Gathering the card
game it's hard there's all these rules
there's things you got to read on every
card what if that game was digital and
it did all the hard parts for you and
you just played like a pro that's what
matches the Gathering Arena can do for
you uh you can play it on a computer you
can play it on your phone this year
Magic the Gathering is celebrating its
30th Anniversary it's bigger than ever
baby in MTG Arena that's what the kids
call it you can learn to play you can
collect cards you can challenge your
friends you can build decks to show off
your favorite fandom because they got
all sorts of stuff they got like horde
kind of cards I got sci-fi cards horror
I really gotta hit my RS Jason
cards you know what I'm talking about
there's beautiful women on the cards and
beautiful men on the cards great artwork
I love to see it do they have a centaur
uh I believe
I've been drawn to a half man half horse
Brandon can let me just yeah I'll play
it let's pretend I'm someone from the
chat okay okay I'm gonna sip like me
playing I don't read the chat I'm Tommy
Bechtel
yes you can play uh simp in the chat oh
goody no I just have to save up for a
burner phone because a real phone is way
out of my budget no no trash bags 35 at
Walmart I can do that I'm sorry should I
switch the garbage bag and my pants are
wishes well my shoes are hopes and
dreams that never come true we believe
in you jack uh we believe in you anyways
uh it's it's certainly a great entry
point to get into magic for the first
time or get back into magic if you
haven't played for a while like I said
you can download the game on mobile
tablet or desktop to play I honestly do
play this game it's really great because
I never had friends that played magic uh
I did have magic friends uh but narrow
friends I play Magic so I never had to
play as a kid but I I'm super into it
now and it's great uh and like I said I
don't understand all the rules but it
makes it much easier to play uh and they
also have a YouTube channel where they
can give you tips all sorts of stuff go
deeper into the lore of the game it's
great so to get started with magic the
Gathering Arena just click the link in
the description below and download arena
for free and begin assembling Your
Dragon deck to take today
I'm going to download it tonight and I'm
going to report back tomorrow during
this segment do it and how it goes
because I have never played Magic the
Gathering before it's very fun but I
will try I'm gonna download this dang
app someone in the chat just shout out
said reverse it starts in the chat
soon bodies yes and they got to deal
with all that stock weight the
equusapiens from sorry to bother you
rather have the horse head here
what do you want for dinner
I don't like how many farm animals
the goat says
going back to some more
like you guys had line number seven uh
Entertainment Tonight recently released
some interview footage with Charlie Cox
which adds some additional info to the
original Daredevil variant and Daredevil
Daredevil Daredevil darede their double
Works they're double their debate okay
so in the interview Charlie Cox says you
know Marvel Studios president Kevin
feige has been very clear about it being
season one and not a season four so it's
a whole new deal you know and we've been
saying this before we said on the break
room before I said in my breakdown the
exact same quote because they just want
you to know that not everything from
season three is gonna go into season
four but even to go further they might
just completely scrap his origin story
from the Netflix series right possibly
you guys so it goes on to say in the
interview every now and again they start
back at the beginning of Murdoch's
Journey as a little boy and they tell
the whole origin story again so maybe
we'll get to do that I just don't really
so we gotta watch his daddy get Beat to
Death again I hope not man because it's
the thing is it's still what I'm stuck
on is it's still called Born Again which
we know that issue is but think it's
called born again because he's born into
Marvel Studios 100 because how are you
gonna not talk about the comic
touch on some of those
absolutely and we've we you know we've
kind of been confused because you know
they they had this stuff again this was
at d23 but they're kind of just
releasing this interview today yeah or
earlier this week so we kind of saw for
the first time and this is kind of what
Charlie Cox has been saying that's the
line he's been Towing where it's like
it's it's different it's not the same
it's a new start but then there was that
kind of blurb on a a Disney site or a
Marvel site that was like oh it's the
same the same Matt Murdoch the same guy
you know and it's like okay well is it
different or the same and if it is the
same what about everything else that's
attached yeah I think the same as far as
actors and the roles they betray because
again Vincent D'Onofrio is Wilson fist
but again he was fist with the Hawaiian
shirt on it was very different it was a
different Fisk you know I'm saying he
wasn't the same he was aggressive but he
was just marvelous you know they're
marble type colorful you know so each of
them are as is this Daredevil we saw so
I think that's what it is yeah but it's
still the people you know because
everybody was like nobody else could
play Daredevil but Charlie Cox right
nobody else can be Kingpin but Vincent
D'Onofrio so that's who we get when I
can accept that kind except it's not who
cares if I accept it or not but like the
concept of you have
two universes that are very close to
each other and everything is the same up
until a certain point in time and like
maybe in the original Netflix series
there is no snap something goes
different there but in our Series this
Daredevil and this Wilson Fisk look the
same act the same had the same story
points but uh they lived through a
Marvel that has a snap and all that and
this this Charlie [ __ ] this Daredevil
never knew Jessica Jones never knew I
was like the Defenders didn't exist to
him okay I would accept that I think
that's where it's kind of already going
because they with what we saw in
She-Hulk where like she just didn't know
who he was that I think that's kind of
how they're going to introduce him more
into the MCA was like what happened for
you was in Hell's Kitchen which is not I
mean not small but by no means but
compared to everything that's happened
already between that series and between
the Netflix series it's like so much
stuff happened for us that we don't know
about the little vigilante in Hell's
Kitchen I'm like we don't know to just
kill eight blocks Eric square blocks
people and then people some people will
probably be like wait weren't you the
guy that was just killing innocent
people because in the third man he was
out here yeah he was out here murdering
people in the whole news office yeah
well and also a big sticking point for
Daredevil and he brings it up in
She-Hulk is that like people don't know
who I am I've kept the identity of Matt
Murdoch separate from from Daredevil I
mean now She-Hulk knows obviously but
like she knows in the biblical no she
knows she knows she knows he knows so
like it would be interesting because by
the end of season three of the Netflix
series for their alert
uh King Pen wasn't first knows that Matt
Murdock is Daredevil and starting that
over is like a new twist uh if if this
Kingman has to figure that all out again
is very interesting so I don't know
sorry we keep getting into something I'm
so sorry quicker this is why Zach
doesn't it not me because I will stay on
them I'm stretching this uh so the
werewolf will go quickly this is our
last one where we'll buy night star
teases a surprising timeline for the
character Jack so Gael Gael Garcia
Bernal Bernard uh says who knows Jack
Russell may have been alive for the last
200 300 or 400 years so how would a
character like this or someone that has
lived so many years would react to the
mundane or to the day-to-day how would
the conversations be engaged you know so
things like that and there's a big
possibility with a character like this
to go into different tangents and to try
out different things leaning that this
character we could get another story of
of like how literally the funny part
it's just this guy that's like 400 years
old yeah and then put him in like an
Apple Store like putting them in today's
timeline how the hell was he gonna react
don't sell any apples do you think he's
been asleep then or because he's hanging
out he must have been alive he's like I
still have like going on iPhone three if
he's been alive for 400 years my man
should have started like a checking
account very early on he's in the First
Bank yeah
get some gold bear in your backyard
you're a dog really he has to have that
though because remember he said in the
series I have contingencies in place
right for when the full moon happens so
he just started building stuff and got
money stacked up he's been doing these
type of things he's just like yo I got a
regular phone I got a Nokia I play Snake
on this phone it's real cool it's
calming I ain't got no internet I don't
know what this Tweeter is I don't know
he's looking through 10x is money I've
got a great crypto like is it thrust to
the Moon oh it's called smack smack
so much or the special presentation when
I was watching again I noticed all the
little like dog affectations he has like
when he's talking uh uh in inside the
mausoleum uh and he goes to sit down
right before he sits down he spins
around yup he does a full turn
yup he does the scratch which is obvious
but there's a lot of dark and like when
he's put in a situation like that he
immediately kind of just like sits down
and relaxes like a dog let's just chill
yeah he's very cute where I told my wife
his name is Jack Russell she goes
we want to talk about Andor we want to
add that stoppage time Fray girl saying
hey Jay you came back why do you why do
you like more men thing Ted who do you
like more man thing or Swamp Thing uh I
want man thing because here's why Ted
here's Ted had a motion too yeah Ted was
a person those eyes you know he just was
like all right look I'm just trying to
live they didn't put this damn thing in
my back bro I didn't want to be here I
was trying to be out in these streets
you know I'm saying getting these Force
chicks but then they called me you know
I'm saying you got swamp things just
like
I'm sad uh there's no depth this morning
what if she doesn't want me I'm green I
love her it's not easy being Abby Abby
Arcane doesn't want me Jessica okay
she doesn't want me she's the guy you
get stuck out at the bar when like you
notice all your friends already left and
you're like oh no I'm the last one here
with Swamp Thing he's like hey what are
you drinking he's like he's like get him
another you're like all right
no I told you that story to tell you
this story and you're like oh I used to
be a ball player yeah she almost made a
major lease I'm playing for the White
Sox blew out blew out my knee and a
Cabbage Patch and the Cavs what were you
doing I was at the Cabbage Patch doll
factory putting the heads on the dolls
this is the thing I used to do you're
starting to sound like you're from New
Jersey one thing I I am I'm from Trenton
but I got drafted by the White Sox I
encounter my love for beefs what
diabetes
so they took me to Chicago and I ate all
the beef so they made me work it off and
the Cabbage crab that's what drugs do
they ramble and they change all right
that's enough from Swamp Thing let's get
to our main discussion today uh and this
was some kind of late breaking news
before we kind of had to rewrite the
show a little there was a press release
that came out uh around black panther
wakanda forever and Disney provided some
more insights into the plot details for
said film uh and these were kind of
fascinating there were quotes from both
uh the director uh Ryan coogler and one
of the producers Nate more uh one of the
things that Ryan Cooper the producer's
name is Nate Moore Nate Moore like
Neymar oh that is very close I even
notice did you not guess you didn't get
him the first time this is the first
time this is a fake art do you think
they were [ __ ] with me no that's his
real name
more if you're out there come on the
show it's a Blackberry of course who
could forget the cinematographer T Chaka
stop absolutely not Sean Patrick here we
go
now we don't know if
some articles were kind of posting this
is oh they're doing a time Jump but we
don't know when t'challa died in the
timeline okay that's what I was about to
say because I was like there's rumors
that it's take place in 2022 or 23 but
right we don't know in the timeline
where it fits but we know when this film
begins t'challa has been dead for like a
year uh or that will be the main
timeline of the movie takes place a year
after after his death
um and shuri is like still not dealing
with it well and queen raimonda decides
to kind of take her on like a retreat to
do this kind of grief ritual to connect
with nature to get her out of the lab
because I guess she's just been like you
know absorbed in the lab not dealing
with stuff so she's a year afterwards is
still pretty emotionally upset by this
whole thing as anyone would be uh and
it's on this kind of uh Retreat and
nature that they're first approached by
Namor uh who kind of has like a position
of protection kind of warning them that
wakanda is not as safe as they think
which is you know we've seen from kind
of from the trailers you know Roman just
saying like you know you guys guys are
all after us now that our King's dead
you know we we feel the heat coming we
feel it coming right but that's kind of
fast ing stuff that already in this
article they're kind of setting it up
we're like Namor and we've suspected
he's not the main villain of this movie
like the trailer does make it seem like
a bad guy but there's probably a third
act Baddie I don't like that they're
making it out it's already map like like
the the mob being like we can pay you
for protection so like say it the best
way I don't like the fact they make
these black people need saviors okay
they've been straight for for
Generations in wakanda you know what I'm
saying right yes they've had the Black
Panther as the protector of wakanda but
they've also got this badass Squad
called the door melange just as much so
it's like neighbor being like hey you
see me just walk about this water in
these Wings on my ankles I can help I'm
like what are those wings
[Applause]
you know what I'm saying like I don't
that's the only thing I don't like the
fact that he has to feel like yo I can
protect y'all bro you we're good I I
like the way that we're like yeah no I'm
fine I don't need you in your tiny ankle
bracelet and then we see whale come out
of the water and I'm like wait a minute
wait wait do we think though is there's
a rhino we know the third act oh that's
true feeling we were hoping for is maybe
Doom or some other like
it's gonna end up being like the leader
of like a un country that's are they
going to pull a Top Gun yeah it'll be or
like it'll be like the general like just
like a deep power in general it's our
like Thunderbolt Rock I don't know I
think you know I I have a lot of faith
in what they're gonna do with this I
think it's Doom uh well it's two hours
and 46 minutes right so they do have the
time to introduce they can fully tell
Neymar's kind of introduction to the MCU
and introduce a bigger threat with
plenty of time to spare to pay off him
starting off as an adversary and then
them all having to team up against this
bigger villain I don't think Doom is
like I I get where you're going but I
think Doom is like a post-credit reveal
because he's so big to the to the whole
he's the one who sets everything in
motion who do you think it is
colonizes as always right because
remember the government has been trying
to get into wakanda for the longest and
now they have it don't they have to have
some kind of super weapon to pay off the
final fight like you know like all right
this is true that's all right that's how
I get what you're saying yeah because if
it's just a bunch of dudes with like
machine guns and like helmets it's kind
of like all right well obviously the
wakandans and the but if this is a
situation where there's a super soldier
CRM or like their hyper-powered soldiers
or they've you know made a synthesized
version of the heart-shaped herb like
that's all could be playing into it this
press release also does seem to indicate
it's when Namor is making this
proposition when raimonda and Sherry are
away from wakanda that something happens
there that kind of like proves the point
uh whether that's instigated by name or
not I don't know I was kind of
theorizing that you know maybe Neymar
doesn't want this war but his brother or
someone out like a Tuma or nomura dies
and an action is taken not on his behalf
but on the behalf of his people and then
he's like sorry I got a side with my
people yeah I'm now I'm now I hate you
guys do you think we could lose do you
think they would kill embaku or
something like that well why would you
sacrifice
why you can't sacrifice wakabi he was a
snitch and a Trader he's not coming back
to them can you cast somebody else for
him but you know do you think he might
or they could start with like he oh well
no no yeah I don't want to see him back
I don't want him to die I think that was
the first person
it's not gonna be sacrificed he's
actually he's actually gonna live
through the whole movie I hope he does
they got it but I hope he admits he went
to Brighton High School instead of
saying he's from Brooklyn
recently
they recently
wrote uh uh a meet and greet in Baku you
can go see a Disney's California
Adventures and Avengers campus you can
also now you can also be well oh you can
um you can also meet with uh you know uh
uh Steve Rogers who's dead with Tony
Stark who's dead you can be with me
with kylo Ren who's dead you could also
be with Karen who is uh you know a
genocidal Maniac uh you can shake hands
with him well it's not my fault that I
love him so much
guys stop letting your daughters take
pictures with Darth Vader he's a bad boy
he's a bad boy and fathers ma'am ma'am
did you hear her she's a problem she's a
problem it's okay Jessica wants to go to
Disneyland with me I'm like I can't get
kicked out I'm gonna go as Jessica's
chaperone here's the thing though
together we'll both be arrested she
wants to be just choked she'd let to be
known she can't just sprain it on Darth
Vader like yes I've got some deep break
room more for you you need to read oh
yeah there's a little piece of fiction
that I think is going to explain a lot
of this is
the third sister and Darth Vader yeah
folks the third sister in Darth Vader
well well a little bit
that's that one's called Force here's
unnecessary Force no very necessary for
us I'm not giving any of you guys credit
uh write it right out all right you got
it here's here's the most fascinating
part of this press release uh and I
think the most overlooked part uh
producer Nate more don't know if he's
real or not no he's very wrong Nate
Moore added that the wakandans are
completely unaware of Neymar and his
people when they meet for the first time
so this is like a big I don't want to
call it a retcon but a big change from
the comic books because uh wakanda and
Atlantis were added from day one right
they knew about each other for a long
time even before the rest of the world
knew about them they were like we
already got beef and and then uh they
have diplomats in each other's countries
like it's a big deal and I believe it's
either Infinity war end game the Dora
milage are aware of like a disturbance
in the ocean yeah it was during end game
uh when Okoye they're having the little
holograph meeting and she brings up
there with some earthquakes she's like
it's an earthquake yeah yeah underwater
yeah yeah take care of yourself like
let's get down there let's [ __ ] some
[ __ ] up and everyone's like Natasha dye
your hair you look ridiculous take care
of yourself Yo now that was somebody
going through grief she was around here
just eating peanut butter and jelly
sandwich just like y'all just I have a
fun fact about it you guys want to hear
about it later it's behind the scenes
and
and Scarlett Johansson look like a mean
person
oh I don't want to hear about that
I don't know who uh neighbor is what
can we sorry we reacted as negatively to
hearing Scarlett Johansson might have
been mean about a haircut as Jay did
about killing him
there's the old one-to-one right there
we don't want to hear it we don't want
to hear bad news yeah you can't say that
about her you can't say it about it uh
it keeps getting in that super
attachment so close to some stoppage
time uh uh uh J Ry me Leah saying heck
yeah friends from other kids nerd babies
and trash bags unite we do our best to
unite Corey can drilly or Kendra Lee
saying I hear something weird coming
from Jay's chest and I like kids
if you're adopted and I like I like it
if you're a doctor out there in the chat
and you heard you think there's a
problem
all of the amateur doctor just like to
email me about my medical element
[Laughter]
because I don't need to hear them
anymore
well we all like being healthy right and
we love living on a healthy planet yes
we're making small decisions every day
we're trying to help the planet can have
a big impact over time like making small
decisions about your health every day if
you keep your money in most standard
bank accounts oh boy do I have news for
you they're lending your deposits out to
fund oil and coal you can switch to the
planet side and get aspiration
aspiration is fossil fuel free and let
you plant a tree by rounding up every
swipe of your debit card that's right
aspirations been hard at work helping
people align their money with their
values funding the planting of over a
hundred million trees even a psychopath
with a chainsaw couldn't cut down all
those trees
Jay is like why am I here I'm so afraid
of all three of you uh best of all with
aspiration there's no credit check no
overdraft fees and with aspiration you
just pay what you think is fair even if
that's zero because money shouldn't
stand in the way of you doing the right
thing uh you can make your dollars make
a difference and open an aspiration
account at aspiration.com break room
debit and move your money out of fossil
fuels help save the planet with your
aspiration debit card open your account
at aspiration.com break room debit today
that's aspiration.com break group debit
terms and conditions to apply and now an
OG is going to tell you about aging okay
we want to thank our sponsors athletic
greens delicious we're such big fans of
the ag-1 it makes it so easy to get all
my vitamins my daily nutrition in one
easy and tasty drink baby I can't get
enough I do triple shots of this thing
you should do that I don't think that's
a good idea I cut my arms open
every scoop of ag-1 has 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Food Source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens
this special blend of ingredients
supports a lot of Health stuff including
better sleep quality mental Clarity and
alertness
whoa look at that ag-1 is one thing you
can do every single day to take great
care of yourself reclaim your health and
arm your immune system with convenient
daily nutrition it's just one scoop and
a cup of water every day that's it one
scoop your simps to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you a
free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin D and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
that's a good deal get some ag1 we're
losing it
yeah all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com break room again that
is athletic greens.com break room
take ownership over your house and pick
up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance it's time for mandatory fun oh
that was quick you slipped right into
that I'm ready for mandatory fun the
segment so electric that we made our
graphic eclectic hit it again
beautiful this segment that ziggs and
zags so we don't try to put ourselves in
closed bags hit the graphic again I'm
confused the segment that keeps you on
your toes so play that graphic everybody
knows and we just got some and or time
oh baby
one story ag1 dropping in everybody's
mouths I think okay okay
you won't get your dessert if you don't
finish your aging we did just get a big
old Super Chat from Jose Rodriguez
saying my last break room for the next
three months going to miss you guys oh
wow yes you'll make me laugh and smile
in my Gloom meeting well we wish you the
best Jose
I'll do a couple extra push-ups at home
on your behalf yeah and I won't but I
will but I will uh uh be thinking about
you I'll get up at like five in the
morning yes yeah yeah uh yeah good luck
out there and thank you to all super
travelers to help us give us that
stoppage time today we'll have that on
at the end of the show so stick around
yeah we're gonna convince Jay to watch
Andor but now
hit the graphic again
now it's time for mandatory fun the most
popular segment on the internet where I
get my three best friends in the whole
wide world together for some fun that
they can't say no to now we're gonna uh
cover our Andor predictions uh let's
just put it this way only my character
lived so everyone else got points and I
did not uh because I'm an idiot and I
pick last and my good doctor is
somewhere on that planet with that tribe
just wondering I I believe she's dead I
think she got her throat slide a doctor
yeah so we're covering our indoor
predictions since I did not confirm get
killed on camera I have reason to
believe she had her throat slashed in a
crime no Lauren got shot first Gorn was
the first one killed in that battle it
was he was Sean that battle Yeah so I
get extra points because I was the first
one I got shot of the extra points
Lauren got shot at me oh by the way
spoiler banner I guess if you haven't
watched and or uh well we usually talk
about it the next day after a drop so so
yeah so they're all dead except for me
so I'm in dead last now Lucas TMI what's
the consistency these bricks in the chat
for Lucas pooping anyway today it's time
for She-Hulk it's our fitness Valley
tonight it's our finale tonight baby I
gotta stay up till midnight again I
can't handle this guys I'm not sleeping
well because all this stuff drops at
midnight now werewolf by night tomorrow
thank God so I can get a good night's
sleep on Thursday into my Friday right
after the Thursday night football game
only on Amazon anyway Bear Down by the
way Bear Down bear down now you may have
to bear with a devastating loss do we
have our reconciliations from last week
Jay picked really well for me last year
Jay did a great job oh look at the
scores there's the scores
okay I've been dead last by a wide that
isn't dead last I've got uh 47 points
Zach said 42 points Jessica's at 50
points right and our trash bags
unfortunately our 55 points no this is
this is how the scoring broke out okay
uh uh uh Brandon on behalf of Jay got
five points for getting the Luke
Jacobson insults on the note there were
seven insults yeah Buffalo no one got
points for pug run time because exactly
two minutes I clocked it 14 seconds
and he did a let's go that's all he got
uh and then uh we had a post-credits
scene it was a yes or no and then uh if
yes what will it be we didn't have a
post credit scene both Jessica and Zach
said no they got five points apiece for
that that's what I was going bro well
that's awesome glad to see him in dead
freaking laughs are getting whatever
also I noticed one person said it
because I don't I think we did talk
about it but we're going over our
predictions for She-Hulk and Andor that
is what we're doing right now don't ask
anymore clearly there's trash bags on
the bottom what are we gonna hang a
trash bag on the wall if they win we had
some we had some like fall show
predictions yes that will pay out these
are gonna there's big point it's
anybody's games right if you call this
like dead on I say you got to get like
50 points and just win this yeah yeah I
remember
She-Hulk will say She Hulk smash at some
point and she has said it no yeah she
said it oh we said one for the entire
years
at the beginning
this is my time okay mandatory fun hit
my graphic again
I'm the king of this segment
all right the segment so hot Wired
Magazine called it oh God Jeremy you
burnt dinner again all right now it's my
brother's name okay anyway so what we're
gonna do is uh
everyone's going to predict what's going
to happen in this episode closest to
this prediction this is like final faces
Jessica what's your prediction um I
wrote mine so Excuse me while I read it
out loud oh you got a whole thing oh
yeah I well we so our new while we're
doing our finales we want to make sure
we are more in depth about it even so
just to hit it on nail in the coffin
icing on the cake we want to make sure
that we actually hit it hit it on so we
went in depth and I have a lot of
evidence to back it up actually with
assets so after deducing that the
Intelligentsia resides at the Twilight
summers The emile's Retreat Abomination
will be revealed as one of its members
and Hulk finds out about what happened
at the gala from sakar keeping tabs on
Jen that's when the leader announces
himself and the fighting starts Bruce is
beating the crap out of abomination Jen
is beating up the leader Titania is
beating up Todd slash Hulk because it'll
be changed by then and Daredevil is
there beating up the men from the
intelligence Intelligentsia and
assisting gen in a swift Dancy fight
scene oh my God I said you say leader
you mean capital L leader yeah Capital
leader yes yes this is uh the leader Tim
Blake Nelson okay so what we know I just
want to back this up what we know is we
know that Todd was named Hulk slash Todd
and the credits a while back can you
confirm for me when you see the photo
asset because I can't see it uh there
are no assets oh okay so okay
um yeah so well it was it was in the
screener it was only just when the
screeners went out the initial credit
said Todd slash talk oh I've never paid
attention to the credits in the screen
as I just watched the episode when the
regular episode came out Disney plus
that it was just removed wow okay so but
then someone released it on Reddit ages
later but again it could have been an
intern [ __ ] up the credits and it was
now fired either way I think it led to
something we also still have uh behind
the scenes of Daredevil in costume Adam
Mill's Retreat that was posted on
Twitter you think he's still there
because he said I gotta leave town no
he's still there and I think evidence is
this photo but you gotta remember
Titania has pictures of her with uh with
Madison like titanium has been doing
everything what everybody now so this
photo I'm like why are you at a meals
Retreat I think that they're at the pool
they're just hanging out and also
because I think they're both comedians
that I think this is outside of work I
think they were both just like let's
just have fun because Jamila Jamil has
now just changed her uh Twitter to
Titans yes that's what I'm saying her
Twitter is just typed and she's amazing
on it too she's great she goes in on
people God bless her Josh
voice too yeah it's good
um and then we also know that Titania
posted on Twitter her dancing at a meals
retreat with the Wrecking Crew behind
her so The Wrecking Crew will also be
making an appearance in the last episode
which makes sense because we know that
one of them is there right one of the
members is there from the last episode
and I said in my breakdown I don't trust
him and I don't trust him and I knew it
and I have reasoning and last but not
least I'm sorry this took a minute we
saw Hulk and Abomination fighting in the
finale trailer so we know that they're
fighting and I think if we see Titania
there there's this like 50 50 whether
she's gonna turn good for a minute or
turn bad and I still think at the end of
the day Titania is still like I'm a
woman and I identify with what happened
with She-Hulk and she's an influencer so
she knows a lot about the internet and
would probably be like I'm against them
revenge porn in you yeah but according
to the Bible women are treacherous
and boss also said this too that it
could just be a misunderstanding or it
could be them just being like full
time's sake and that could happen
um but I just think ultimately I think
for good storytelling and through my
breakdowns I've hinted at why I think a
meal is still up to no good and so it
would back up my theory but I think it's
okay to have different all right well uh
Tommy let's hear your awful take on this
so uh here's my prediction guys first
things first let the men sort it off
okay no I'm just kidding I'm kidding I'm
kidding camera three please so I can
read it I forgot what I said Jennifer
is oh this is the second half okay so
the first half of my prediction is
She-Hulk after her Outburst is put on
trial yeah we last saw her like yeah got
guns she's arrested and uh put on trial
and then uh she uses uh Emile Blonsky
and Bruce Banner as character Witnesses
about why the Hulk you know when when
pushed uh emotionally or being
manipulated the way that she was why are
you laughing we listened to an hour and
a half of your Theory come on don't
laugh at me please
I laughed because I thought about how
you said in the Bible women are
treacherous and that was treacherous you
derailed me to my theory you don't want
me to win no
no hey y'all I'm just happy
I just need someone to be the wind
beneath my wings I'm always here for
that but geez Louise all right anyway I
lost my train of thought I'm so sorry
their character Witnesses their
character Witnesses in the trial Nikki
and pug are of course her co-counsel
maybe even her lead counsel maybe she
has to take a back seat to this she is
found guilty okay put her in jail got
her the same jail Blonsky was in she's
art with all the lasers and everything
like that now after that the
Intelligentsia emerges okay there's a
threat we need to get her out they give
her a special release they're like okay
we actually need all of our Hawks
because intelligencia has hulks now I
mean some Hulk on Hulk action so you get
Pulaski fighting for the sign of good
that's why it's different than yours
just so we know just so people aren't
like this is the same theater I didn't
say that yeah I think we're different no
no I know I wasn't saying I'm sorry this
was not a confrontational remark towards
you this was me pointing out Sports
this is not the same Theory blotsky
fighting with Hulk with She-Hulk with a
daredevil Cameo uh they're fighting the
intelligence yet they defeat the
Intelligentsia last thing is Jennifer
returning to her job at the law office
where she learns from her boss she has
been disbarred oh no longer a lawyer I
think the disbarred part is on the money
because I think there's something still
up with holding home away
you're right yeah he's gotten off way
too easy we still yeah they still what
what is the excuse they said for Titania
crashing through the wall they said uh
blood sugar and she was on her way to
get it I'm with you you're dead on with
that that is way too convenient I don't
know I don't know uh here's my
prediction for the finale okay I think
Hulk is irritated he's mad Bruce Banner
is kind of still yeah he wouldn't like
him when he's a little irritated uh
because Jen didn't have to put in the
work that he did remember this was in
the first episode it's kind of annoyed
because she doesn't have like the same
split personality problem the idea the
problem of like Hulk and Bruce right Jen
was already in sync so he's already kind
of like irritated by that whole
situation I think he's going to regress
a little bit and when he comes back and
he sees abomination in person for the
first time
the Hulk comes back Hulk is done
triggered Hulk's back now and it's Hulk
versus Bruce again and it's Hulk that
causes some damage which results in him
being locked up in the same facility
that Abomination was locked up in and
the Cliffhanger will be that now Jen has
to represent Bruce to help get Bruce
back out of prison because now our Hulk
is locked away and I think this is going
to do some permanent damage to the smart
Hulk and we're going to be left with an
angry Hulk which could help get us to
World War Hulk because that's how those
events started when the world didn't
know how to deal with Hulk I like yours
is leaning
I think Hulk's seeing abomination in
person for the first time is gonna
unlock some some things on the inside
okay first off I know what you're
laughing at and all John said was Jay
sets the car
I just we the people in the chat aren't
right we have all predicted a nine hour
finale and then James is just Sakura
which I think is this no so I wrote
something else because I didn't know how
so I got a text message like hey it
wasn't even an email because I probably
would have put more in the email you're
representing Zach so we want to make
sure Zach gets the least amount of
people yeah that's fine
sorry Zach uh this is we did too good
last week so oh he's bringing out the
receipts
that's my fault this was typed wrong
Jason
Luke song and then anyway Scott okay so
what I believe is since I it's not
written up on the prompter uh we'll find
out that Josh was just a Lackey he was
just trying to get paid he has no real
pool or anything the leader is showing
up for sure but he's more so showing up
in the post credit or probably one or
two post credits real quick Hope's
coming back with his kid that's why he
had to go this car that's why he had to
leave he's got his kid he was out here
just busting everybody down when he was
in the Gladiator thing he was just
busting everyone down he was skeeting
raw shoes at the club he was beating
cheese
Magnums are out here pushing it it took
me a minute to recognize what you said
and I was like
shoot up the club baby is that weird uh
mesh that the uh people in Guardians of
the Galaxy have that weird mesh thing oh
when they're in space yeah to put up
that's what you got to put on the hole
because yeah anyway so
let's please demonstrate
we can only do so much on YouTube
this is really I see the fish okay
so his kid will come back like I said
jyn has to deal with she's Savage
She-Hulk now that's why she won't I
agree she will not be a lawyer anymore
she'll be Savage She-Hulk this show is
She-Hulk attorney at law and also this
is setting up just leading to season two
I was gonna say do you I think this
would be a good prediction for you that
we can give to Zach oh yeah do you think
uh do you think that uh I have a biting
Kink uh do you think that that the end
we'll get the Loki thing that's right
yes
she's not showing up in Captain America
new world order right she's definitely
not because yes the leader is that in
that but she won't be in that her show
has not set up anything for her to go to
the movies I think she set it up for
armor Wars I like her in Thunderbolts
that's what I say there's too many and I
like her in the acolyte a lucasfilm Star
Wars series someone did ask are we gonna
see who Hulk had a child with yeah I
think he's gonna bring his kid um
no because she's probably destroyed
she's destroyed we're like
it's one leg this way it'll level it all
the way over here it's like the
screaming Dinosaur Jurassic Park
that's literally what it's like just
like this someone said a Hulk throws
rope confirmed oh my God there's an
awful passage
East of Eden that it just made me think
about them just like she just like so
that that Paul okay oh my gosh
let us know who you support more yeah if
Jack are they are they're gonna support
I can't believe no one's supporting me
they should support you Jessica's is the
best there is it after you call me a
treacherous from the Bible from the
Bible
Jessica you know I like women that are
bad for me okay the fact that I've
identified you is
those votes coming in on the poll uh we
want to thank a lot of our super
Chatters because we have unlocked some
Andor stoppage time uh thinking uh uh
Quentin with sending a chat Network
Netflix did a three-part series recently
and also included Beast Wars some good
Nostalgia there I'll have to check that
out yeah I do I always like the Beast
Wars I hated beast machine means that
was terrible you didn't like that these
machines was brutally bad but there's
two different Beast Wars cartoons so
what it was the original yes yeah and
then all of a sudden they got
transported back to Cybertron somehow
yeah and then you know it was just
really yeah
to yourself no no it's not under mine
and I did not mean nervous no take this
back when I come back uh we are staying
over the four o'clock time
in a minute yeah the Andor Top's gonna
so don't leave someone said bye and I
was like no we're still here we're gonna
be here don't go but yeah they uh did
where everybody all the maximals and
Decepticons uh excuse me Predacons left
the planet and went back to Cybertron
for Beast Machines and it was like when
everything was trying to be 3D uh TV
back in the 90s and it didn't look great
oh yes I remember that that's exactly
what it was brutal
like oh I think it's like either late
like early 2000s yeah real early I
remember the show called reboot that
took place inside the internet yes I do
yeah it's that kind of Animation yeah
yeah I'm very early stuff reboot stands
in the chat let me hear you okay maybe
we'll jump out captain in the game
master if we're gonna go any further
back yeah
a Zeo Panthers Super Chat Jen hates the
final episode breaks the fourth wall and
asks feige for one more episode I would
love that we were wondering around the
office like does Jen know when we're
watching chain or when we're not
watching is she aware of us
I forgot about what I thought her uh
post credit scene is I think she if she
doesn't get a season two or either or
her episode ends with a post credit
scene her getting out the shower a la
Ferris Bueller and saying it's done what
are you still here for but guess who's
in the shower with her Wade
oh that's how you introduced Deadpool
he's just in the shower with Jen yeah
Wade Wilson like they're yes yes yes
Jessica that's what you do in the shower
yeah what else are you doing no no you
don't I've only ever showered with
someone so they can get my itsy bitsies
uh
um wait you can do sex in the shower in
this economy
you don't have the crown molding you've
got extra sex in the shower because you
gotta save on water
brushing your teeth in the shower to
save water I don't know if I have the
structural Integrity yeah it's a
terrible way to save uh water because
the shower's running when you're
brushing your teeth that's very wasteful
this is a little bit of water all right
Brandon after this I need 20 minutes of
your time so you can break the stuff
um the mj29s have been putting out they
subscribers Jay's Channel and they're
loving it ah thank you very much I
appreciate it hey not enough people are
liking this video what's wrong was it my
constant outburst and deriving with it I
mean did you not like it well pretend
I'm not on the show and hit that like
button and subscribe to us uh my simple
Tunes my cat is cuter than yours uh
setting a Super Chat love from the UK I
love love to you as well so do you want
you up on down to the public grab
yourself a point oh there's not a cue
for the left on the way uh Mike Glenn
saying Marvel's Kingpin also has
superhuman strength
you could get it on in the water closet
and Netflix
and add some super strength I think so
too
uh Tasha Tasha's saying I've never seen
Android this is just for TV I assume
your TV
also Mr Feeney Carla abara Sarah sending
in super chats all right let's talk
let's talk some Android because we did
get a super chat from Michelle Scalia
saying that and or episode deserves a
few break room minutes but what about
the I love you guys this most recent
episode did feature a very awesome uh uh
astrological event yes that looked
beautiful and was so beautiful to see on
a TV show Jay I just want to tell you
this real fast I'll give you my juice
please here's what the thing I love most
about it do you not have Tommy looking
tomorrow
in the episodes they've released so far
over half the season pull your head that
way
there has nothing it's going into my
fingers snapping a single Jedi there has
not been a single use of the force
mentioned
this is street level Star Wars where
these people don't give them what about
Jedis no I don't care about the Jedis
there's a problem okay these are people
trying to live their lives in a Galaxy
where fascism is on the rise and it's
happening slowly they're The Boiled frog
at first they want it and then suddenly
it's too late right oh the water's warm
oh that's great it feels great frog legs
Jay they're eating frog legs they're
eating frog legs they're hanging your
dad uh from a light pole on the street
the there's insurgents everywhere like
this is the show that rocks okay it is
so good Tony Gilroy is a master uh it's
it's so tense every episode has like
such great uh tension the people are so
believable they eat food you never see
people eat food in Star Wars it's great
they take the bus they eat a Cocoa Puffs
and blue milk it's delicious they have
drivers there's space limits they got
jobs from the first episode Jake there's
two there's two people they're working
for the bad guys they're sitting at
their desks and they're bullshitting
they're like I hate this [ __ ] job
like I hate it too it's like it's real
life yeah it's great it's really good
there's quality control issues for the
Empire you don't know who's gonna live
who's gonna die there's no like platform
well Anders got a ton of plot yeah yeah
armor but that's it people in the chat
are genuinely like there's no Jedis I'm
gonna watch this yes the fact that they
don't bring up the force they don't
bring up Jedis it's great they have an
entire plot point of a kyber crystal
yeah and they don't even know they don't
know what it is they're just like oh
this is worth a lot of them they're just
like yeah oh cool Crystal I wonder if I
could chop it up and snort it you can't
you can't they don't do that there but
there is brothels yeah they do have
broth they got brothels people are
sipping sipping wait time out Tommy's
old teleport ain't no Jedis ain't no
lightsabers they got hoes they got hoes
guess what that's gonna make some of
these trash bags watch I guess there's
confirmed sex in like the first episode
or second episode yeah and it's used in
a very powerful way was it I I guess uh
necessary to put in the brothels into
Andor well I think it just shows it
shows like a seed to your side to the
city
my character is going to work if they
don't have problems absolutely
absolutely not uh
in the first episode you see that this
brothel he's bringing up and one of the
things I kind of like about links to
crack crack up there's like a dancer I
believe she's a Twilight yeah yeah but
she's a holographic yeah and if I walked
into a brothel they had a holographic
dancer I'd be like this is a boy well to
be fair that is canon in the Star Wars
Universe shows hologram dancers that you
get off to watch the Christmas stuff
dancer
yeah do what you want me to do but don't
touch cause I'm not really there okay we
all love her and we all love that song
but continue watch Love Got to Do Got to
Do With It uh nothing in there I could
have never laid a hand on her if she was
a holograph you know what I mean someone
in the chat also asked if it's more
grounded is it more grounded way more
grounded it's like this
that's a table the ground's on the floor
it is it is much worse it's much more
grounded because these characters are
not they're not the superheroes of this
universe okay they're they're just
trying to get by and like survive in a
system and most of them they don't want
to fight they're not trying to have her
but this is about the beginning of the
Rebellion you know when we when we check
in on Like A New Hope right yeah they're
on the Run they're scared they got bases
they got x-wings right they got and
they're all Johnny and Jenny Eagle
Scouts they're like we love the
Rebellion this one a lot of people lying
yeah they pretend they love the
Rebellion you wonder why because they
just gotta eat they gotta eat and don't
Google Star Wars guys do not that's a
different thing do not Google Star Wars
the rebellions
Star Wars right excuse me okay this
isn't for you like even the word the
Rebellion doesn't exist no don't you do
it on our YouTube channel yeah don't be
on our Wi-Fi a rebellion not me yeah
there's a great there's a great line
where Cassie nandor says to one of the
characters about like don't you want to
be a part of something bigger or
something like that he's like saw
Guerrera separatist Insurgent whatever
you all are you're all the same to me
right you're not for me everyone is just
trying to use me to get to an end and I
don't trust any of you all uh because we
learn about a little about andor's
backstory where he comes from like why
he he doesn't trust these people uh it's
pretty fascinating but I have heard and
I've for a lot of people ever since the
Mandalorian and then when what what came
up that I missed that I'm trying not to
look at the chat says hoes you say
everybody
technically he's asking about garden
hose that's true oh perfect he did spell
it wrong no he didn't that's h-o-e-s
that's what's in the chat that's hoes I
know that house those hoes those holes
are there so they got space holes they
got a Far Far Away hoes yeah now hearing
like how the Mandalorian reference the
Jedi force et cetera et cetera Obi-Wan
same thing Ashoka is going to do that
the fact that Andor has been something
that people have been asking for for
years do a story that's nowhere
connected to the Skywalker family
nowhere connect so I think I will agree
I will check this out we got one
and bonus not to throw shade at another
Prestige television show right now you
can see everything in the show without
having to be in an ultra dark sensory
deprivation room well sure you're
talking he's got a bad TV and can't see
houses
you've got a tube tell me Tommy's trying
to watch House of the Dragon an outdoor
sports bar yeah you guys I I watch I
watch all my videos of the Dragon
episodes at Hooters hey can I get the
lemon pepper and the targaryens right
with the dry garlic rub and then also
order some wings who treats women better
uh Westeros or Hooters
who treats women better West rules are
Tommy
no they call me they call me Tommy
Targaryen Mr Tommy over here sad but the
boys
my spiders give me information about the
ladies of Kingsley Tommy dips his hand
in dirt and then enter the stuff
he's like we can get the baby out but
not a second uh
he could deliver this child perfectly
healthy and natural but there is another
way that I am a little more fun doing
I've got this new knife made of Valyrian
steel I wonder what it will do to a room
like this hey how dare you too far right
this is Jay's fault oh my God so with
Android just because I want to give you
guys
you put it near my mouth and his hands
are dirty
no because you're the masonry
so what's the chance of okay so we're on
episode one of Andor right now I believe
seven seven
six was yesterday yeah we're on six
little six and someone does little
inside videos for it on our YouTube
channel and they're also at this table
Tommy's on rookie leaks Tommy's on
Wookie leaks you try
Darth Thomas King of The Wookie leaks
yes you need to watch and or guys watch
the Wikileaks breakdown we're so
energetic we're so enthusiastic we want
you to watch this show with us have fun
with us otherwise I have to ignore you
like I usually do
in the chat we're asking do you need to
watch like all of the Star Wars second
of Star Wars so you don't even need to
watch Rogue one no you don't need to
watch them honestly you should watch it
and or first and then go Rogue one and
or butts about it this this series she
was waiting on this one that was the one
even when he built all day this series
takes place five years before Rogue one
okay she's also five years before A New
Hope right uh and the plan for this show
is uh there's 12 episodes this year uh
and then next year there's gonna be
another oh so there's another season of
Andorra oh yes
my biggest pitch for this was Tony
Gilroy he directs Rogue one he loves it
and Kathleen Kenny's like we're going to
make some more movies in this thing and
then all the other movies do terrible
and Kathleen Kennedy's we're not going
to make any more movies yeah and he's
like okay that's great and Tony Gilroy
is ready to go on with his life uh and
she's like do you want to come make a
show but set with these characters and
he's like ah not really I'm kind of not
into it
they she's like okay we've been working
on it can we send you like our treatment
he's like yeah I'll take a look at it
takes a look at it what he sends back is
basically an essay of like this
treatment is bad and here's why it's bad
uh and they're like and here's what you
should do to fix it and they're like do
you want to come do this and he's like
yes uh one thing that's great about this
show too if you've watched all these new
Star Wars series you can tell when
they're shooting on the volume right yes
it's very impressive and I think it was
wonderful what they did for Mandalorian
which is great which is usually just one
or two people but when you have like
four characters that are so close to
each other and you can see it as a
volume of the volume they went and shot
at all of these awesome locations and
used like old infrastructure that was
already there and added to it it was a
great special on Disney plus about like
the locations they went to go shoot this
show it's incredible and like the town
that is in the first three episodes yes
they built like that whole town and
they're there it's gonna come back yeah
they're gonna change it up for like
season two
just like incredible stuff and like it
really looked so different it shot so
well the pacing is great there's no
little kid McGuffin in this I just like
to address someone in the chat yeah
Highlander 7321 says can new rock stars
give Jay a job can they please oh boy oh
boy
all right we have one black king
that's a deep cut only one may live when
the other can die here this is what's
happening if you haven't been convinced
to watch Andor yet I beg you give it one
episode a chance right not super long
and then listen to us on Wikileaks and
then listen to my podcast what she
leaking uh
Brandon uh and I will say Eric's
breakdown to the show has been very good
it is not super overt with the Easter
eggs and stuff because it's not like oh
that's that's uh Obi-Wan's lightsaber
it's not that stuff there's little
things hidden in the show that this
connects to everything yeah he's done a
great job pointing it out uh it's great
though it's fascinating they make Tie
fighters look badass they make
everything look impactful and scary okay
it's really good check it out folks
we're imploring you uh and uh as far as
we will never hire Jay if you don't
watch yeah we'll never hire Dave you
don't watch but we will hire him if you
do uh and as for the trash bags out
there you guys via the PO have gone with
Jessica for your final predictions show
uh so welcome which was very wisely
probably
um but that is it for our show today
thank you to all our super Chatters out
there we did get some more from Hector
Rivera saying sometimes 305 sharp
sometimes 305 sharp that's right that's
a call back to a great time yesterday
also I'll never be mad someone said
y'all made just mad I'm never mad
Jessica has to keep us grounded and let
us know when we go this is
unpronounceable we're begging to watch
some Andor uh film juice was asking can
anyone speak his Colin Farrell quote as
Danny DeVito's penguin uh if if it it's
okay if you can't I love you always call
myself
where's all my paint off I gotta drink a
big wolf colon bang Harley Quinn uh it's
over insane body's so nice you gotta hit
the graphic twice hit it again uh uh did
Jay say hope to zoo he said a lot of
things about the hopes member that I
don't want to talk I think special shout
out to Jay for coming back yeah thank
you for having me thank you our super
Chatters out there thanks
for today be sure to tune in each
and here on the break when we're back
tomorrow after watching Shield finale
make sure you watch this video for
tuning in uh we love you all have a
great rest of your one day Wednesday
we'll check y'all next time I'll be the
same time
[Music]
it's true